Eins,
zwei,
drei.
Das geht nicht.
Für Kinder ein Riesenspaß:
Ferien an der Ostsee,
obwohl es grade mal 16 Grad warm ist.
Die Familie Doberstein aus Niedersachsen
ist für eine Woche hier.
Ans Mittelmeer wollen sie
dieses Jahr nicht.
Wir waren sonst schon öfters, ja.
Das letzte Mal war aber jetzt
allerdings vor vier Jahren,
ne, da waren wir in der Türkei, ne, ja.
Aber Fliegen ist im Moment nicht so meins.
Dann lieber in der Heimat bleiben,
auch wenn kaum jemand ins Wasser geht.
Die Ostsee hat eine Temperatur
von nur 18 Grad
– immer noch besser als
ein Urlaub in Angst.
Sonst in den Jahren sind wir
auch viel umhergereist,
Türkei, wo man heute ja momentan
wohl nicht gerne hinfährt
oder auch nicht sollte.
Ist doch alles ein bisschen gefährlich
und auch in den anderen Ländern
weiß man nicht so recht,
was da so passiert.
Ist von der … von der Seite her schon
’ne schlimme Zeit, sag ich mal, ne.
Hier kann man alles vergessen.
Und frieren muss man auch nicht,
in der überdachten Badelandschaft ist
es das ganze Jahr 32 Grad warm.
Und es gibt 200 Meter
lange Wasserrutschen
– der ultimative Kick für
diesen 14-Jährigen.
Auch er ist das erste Mal hier.
Also, eigentlich fliegen wir relativ viel.
Und sonst …
Wohin denn?
Mallorca, Ägypten und sowas.
Also, Sonnenländer.
Und Ägypten dieses Jahr nicht?
Nee, diesmal nicht.
Warum nicht?
Wegen dem IS dort in der Nähe.
4000 Gäste sind zurzeit
in dieser Ferienanlage.
Ausgebucht
– so wie in diesem Jahr die meisten Hotels
an der deutschen Nord- und Ostsee.
Die Reiseweltmeister
bleiben lieber zuhause.
Wir waren jetzt die letzten Jahre
mal Türkei, Mallorca.
Aber Ostsee waren wir schon mehrmals, ja.
Und warum dieses Jahr nicht in die Türkei?
Nee, fliegen war die Woche
Urlaub bisschen kurz.
Da müsste man bisschen
länger machen, ne.
Ist das auch eine Frage der Sicherheit?
Auf jeden Fall.
Sie haben's bestimmt mitbekommen
in den Nachrichten, oder?
Ja, das ist nicht so prickelnd.
Und dann mit Kindern …
Und wir gehen dann einmal
weiter in den Schlafraum
– mit ’nem Doppelbett
und gleich
nebenan dann das Duschbad.
Alles sehr modern eingerichtet,
die sind relativ neu renoviert
und so der Standard.
Das ist so unser klassisches
Zwei-Raum-Apartment.
Kostet pro Übernachtung 150 Euro
– ohne Frühstück.
Und vor Anfragen können sie
sich nicht retten.
Grade heute morgen
trat wirklich die Situation auf,
dass Gäste uns anriefen
und unsere Telefone heißgelaufen sind,
bei denen dann der Türkei-Urlaub
jetzt kurzfristig storniert wurde
und die sich dann bei uns erkundigen
wollten, ob wir noch was frei haben.
Ist so kurzfristig natürlich
’n bisschen schlecht,
aber wir versuchen dann immer
noch mal was… was möglich zu machen.
Alles kostet extra:
Acht Minuten Bungee-Hüpfen
für sechs Euro.
Viele Gäste sind Ausländer,
vor allem Skandinavier.
Die Thomsens aus Dänemark
sind für eine Woche hier.
Auch sie haben sich gegen
einen Urlaub in der Türkei
und für die Ostsee entschieden.
Ich würde da jetzt nicht hinfahren,
auch wenn’s vielleicht übertrieben ist.
Denn wenn ich es richtig verstehe,
gibt’s im Norden der Türkei Probleme.
Im Süden des Landes scheint
es okay zu sein,
aber das will ich gar nicht erst riskieren.
An anderen Urlaubsorten kann
man sich besser erholen.
27 Millionen Gäste kommen jährlich
nach Schleswig-Holstein.
In diesem Jahr haben die
Buchungen noch einmal
um zehn Prozent zugelegt.